this video is brought to you by wix
what's up guys jared again everyone's
been talking about it
every message board every discord server
every major news publication
we've even dipped our toes in on culture
binge you've probably heard of the storm
area 51 facebook event
in which millions of net nerds
ironically vowed to naruto run their way
into area 51 on september 20th so they
can finally
see them aliens now this is funny for a
variety of reasons
there's nothing quite so satisfying as
imagining some general at the pentagon
being briefed on what a group of kyles
is
but it's also a dark joke about
gleefully signing up for
what is essentially a suicide mission
every five seconds a new meme pops up on
the facebook event
ironically strategizing their entrance
taking inventory of vehicles and
infantry
and of course coily commenting how
people's commitment to
irony may outweigh their desire to live
it's this last class of memes that got
us thinking about a popular
sub-genre of memes dominating the land
of posting
depression memes whether it's people
identifying with bart simpson as
literally nothing hits him with a wave
of incredible sadness
or a young boy being visited by
teletubbies labeled anxiety depression
loneliness and overthinking
depression memes seemed to be
millennials and genzir's new form of
free therapy
but the more we thought about it the
more we thought that maybe there's
something else to it that
maybe depression memes can be considered
the most modern development of a certain
philosophical and psychological
sentiment
described over 150 years ago in what is
considered
one of the first existentialist stories
so welcome to this wisecrack vlog
on depression memes and for the love of
god don't try to storm area 51
please but if you do send me pixie dm
aliens
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to wix when we originally
partnered with wix we began working on a
new design for our
website together we were able to
customize and personalize the design in
a way that would showcase our formats
best
getting started with wix is fun and you
can use it for any occasion
from a school project to an online store
wix has all the tools you need to make
a professional and robust website you
can post your own music
curate your store or just showcase your
art with wix templates customizing your
unique website is intuitive
you don't even need to know how to code
so you can focus on showcasing your
work wix also has the option to upgrade
to a premium subscription
so you can get access to unlimited
bandwidth options to host longer videos
and so much more so create your own
website today by going to wix.com
wisecrack and get 15 off all yearly
plans with the code
wisecrack15 and now back to the show
so what is a post there are a bunch of
definitions out there that often include
the idea that they're deliberately
unproductive to online conversation
that they exist for their own sake and
or are made hastily and in poor quality
but the definition we found most
insightful comes from writer gustavo
turner in surface magazine
what is a post if not a pointless
carnivalesque attack against
meaning itself like every aesthetic that
draws from the absurd
data surrealism situationism punk
posting is ultimately a cry of despair
against impending disaster
while turner is apt in likening the
supposed to various absurdist art
movements
we instead find a very specific flavor
of existentialism in the depression mean
it's our contention that this phenomenon
of people posting memes about their
despair
is an extension of a philosophical and
psychological sentiment
immortalized by theodore dostoevsky's
novella notes from underground or
more simply the titular underground man
is functionally a 19th century
proto-poster
to find out what we're talking about
we're gonna have to dive into a little
recap of the book
it portrays the curmudgeonly musings of
the underground man
a tortured recluse who reminisces about
a time he almost had an authentic
connection with another human
it starts off with him proclaiming that
he is sick
not because he's suffering from any
physical ailments but rather from
consciousness or an extreme debilitating
commitment to rationality
the first part of the book depicts his
stream of consciousness as he weaves an
intricate labyrinth of arguments about
topics like reason
freedom and european utopianism before
recounting an unpleasant interaction
with his old schoolmate sverkov he
eventually meets a prostitute named liza
who he tries to redeem
by telling her to change her ways she's
able to get him to open up for a little
while
but he quickly turns back into an apple
and tries to humiliate her as she leaves
he immediately regrets his behavior and
runs after her
but she's long gone the underground man
has remained supremely relevant over
time
dostoevsky's metaphor of the underground
was a major development in modern
literature and continues to be
referenced as an embodiment of rebellion
against traditional value systems
which is all well and good but what does
this extremely lonely and extremely
miserable man have to do with people on
the internet joking about the
disposability of their lives via area 51
memes we think the state of despair
propagated by depression memes
overlaps with the sentiment of the
underground man in four key ways
one inaction both depression memes and
the underground man
emphasize despair over action the point
of posting a meme like the cat in a hat
with the text millennials and gen z's
willingness to die
sneaking up on a kid standing in for
area 51 thinking this is a joke
isn't to inspire the masses to get off
their computer and help millennials or
genzirs
by pushing for economic reform or
greater public mental health options
these memes are often born out of
reflecting on what seems like an
impossible hopeless situation with no
particular orientation towards doing
anything about it
the meme only offers a sense of
identification with hopelessness
the futility of action is key likewise
much of the underground man's deep
unhappiness is due to what he calls
hyper consciousness or a paralyzing
sense of awareness
he claims to be so aware that he sees
both sides of any argument
so instead of choosing a side or
defining himself through any meaningful
action
he does nothing he calls this conscious
inertia
it was not only that i could not become
spiteful i did not know how to become
anything
neither spiteful nor kind neither a
rascal nor an honest man
neither a hero nor an insect now i am
living out my life in my corner
taunting myself with the spiteful and
useless consolation
that an intelligent man cannot become
anything seriously
and it is only the fool who becomes
anything like our melancholy hero
depression memes are defined by a
similar kind of inertia
a feeling of hopeless paralysis 2.
like a good post the underground man is
kind of a troll
when he visits his old friend zverkov he
knows that he and his friends don't like
him
but tags along to a party anyway and
acts like a drunken fool just to spread
the misery around
similarly a depression post looks not
only to express despair
but pervert the sunny optimism of
traditional social media posts
if most people on instagram are curating
their social media personas to project
an image of a perfect life
with attractive successful and
supportive friends a depression meme
looks to bring the grimy underbelly of
feelings to the forefront
think you're accumulating cultural
capital by posting about your sweet
beachfront vacation spot with your sexy
rich family
pew i eat depression for breakfast three
like the underground man a depression
meme is a paradox
part of what has made the psychological
profile of the underground man
so interesting and enduring is that he
is constantly contradicting himself
he says he loves being isolated yet he
yearns for human connection
similarly a depression meme is a cry for
help yet
a resignation to hopelessness the
underground man looks down
on normal people like liza and zverkov
yet
envies them not unlike how a depression
meme is a condemnation of normidem
yet a desire to live a life like theirs
finally the underground man
suffers but takes pleasure in it and of
course
people make depression means for the
lulls why
suffering is the sole origin of
consciousness though i did lay it down
at the beginning that consciousness is
the greatest misfortune for man
yet i know man prizes it and would not
give it up for
any satisfaction 4. finally both the
underground man
and posting represent a rejection of
optimistic political ideas
the underground man spends a fair amount
of time refuting ideas put forward by
nikolai sharinashevsky's image of a
utopia built out of a devotion to reason
that he referred to as the crystal
palace in his work
what is to be done similarly depressing
memes are often a reaction to the
post-cold war
90s a decade built on the promise of a
better world
but to many that didn't happen and now
we only look forward to
sunny possibilities like climate
catastrophes war with iran
and silicon valley ruining everything
under the guise of disruption
like the underground man millennials and
gen zeirs have grown up with the promise
of a better future
only to be hit with sobering realities
that have made us
depressed as such depression memes will
often co-opt positive elements of
popular culture and impose
sad realities on them via text in doing
so it comments on the failure of these
images to deliver any actual happiness
and the lie of positivity that they
perpetuated so
there you have it the underground man is
very much alive in the ethos of
depression memes on the internet
but i want to emphasize here that
depression and other mental illnesses
are a very serious thing
and while some may find levity in these
kinds of things
it's not cathartic for everyone for what
it's worth i always remind myself of the
book's
end where the underground man deeply
regrets rejecting human companionship
yes the state of things might be dismal
and derailing meaning and trolling might
give us the necessary
dopamine hit to get through the day but
it's important that we don't give up
on an incredibly important piece of a
healthy psyche human connection
and i just want to end this vlog with a
quote from the text that will undeniably
speak to anyone who's ever posted a
depression
for we are all divorced from life we are
all cripples
every one of us more or less we are so
divorced from it that we feel at once a
sort of loathing for real life
and so cannot bear to be reminded of it
why we have come almost to look upon
real life as an
effort almost as hard work and we are
all privately agreed
that it is better in books thanks to all
our patrons who support the channel and
our podcast
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and before you go i want to give
another shout out to wix
create your own unique website today by
going to wix.com
wisecrack and get 15 off all yearly
subscriptions with the code
wisecrack15 and as always thanks for
watching guys
peace
[Music]
you